und wir sprechen über den reisestopp
trotz russen ja keinen urlaub mehr für
die reichen putin fans und zwar in ganz
europa das ist das große thema hätte
luxusurlaub während das eigene land
bomben wirft das geht gar nicht und das
sagt jetzt auch witali klitschko kiews
bürgermeister er will einreiseverbote
für russische urlauber in ganz europa im
gespräch mit unserem bild reporter paul
ronzheimer nennt er das einen eisernen
vorhang für russen
muss
wiederkommen wie damals weil der beruf
land
zeigt eine diktatur gezeigt keine
menschenrechte in russland
und deswegen wie hier den mitteln die
was stoppt die
russen müssen wir nutzen
und weil es ist voller ronzheimer 1
zugeschaltet aus care schönen guten
morgen der paul er wie ein eiserner
vorhang jetzt das fordert klitschko im
interview mit dir was genau könnte das
bedeuten dass ihnen dieses thema auch so
eine herzensangelegenheit und wie groß
sind die chancen überhaupt dass es
solche einreiseverbote also zum beispiel
dass keine visa mehr erteilt werden dass
es überhaupt umsetzbar ist
der patrizier wenn man eiserner vorhang
hört dann schaudert es erst einmal weil
man natürlich daran denkt was viele auch
unserer zuschauer noch erlebt haben eben
vor dem fall der mauer vor
89 der eiserne vorhang der die
sowjetunion von europa getrennt hat da
kann man nicht drüber so einfach und
witali klitschko hat jetzt dieses bild
genutzt um zu sagen wir brauchen etwas
wo klar wird dass russen nicht mehr so
einfach nach europa kommen ich habe ihn
gestern abend getroffen und er war
richtig wütend wütend darüber dass
russen einfach in griechenland feiern
dass die frau von dimitri peskow auf dem
sprecher dieses dem sprecher von
wladimir putin dort eine party gefeiert
hat das hat gesagt das was sind das denn
für einreisesperren die damals verhängt
wurden wenn selbst die frau des
sprechers von wladimir putin in
griechenland feiern kann wie weit das
umgesetzt werden kann das ist offen denn
es gibt gegner davon unter anderem olaf
scholz der deutsche bundeskanzler der
sagt nein das ist nicht das richtige
denn dann würde man ja auch diejenigen
treffen die dagegen sind und olaf schoss
part darauf dass das putins creekside
und nicht der krieg aller russen aber
auch da gibt es streit in europa denn
zum beispiel in estland finnland und
schweden da sieht man das anders also
ein eiserner vorhang für urlaubs russen
ganz europa das will vitali klitschko in
dem gespräch mit dir wir sehen hinter
die russische panzer dort mitten in kiew
darauf gehen wir gleich einen wollen
aber zunächst in dein interview schauen
mit vitali klitschko und das sind die
wichtigsten aussagen daraus exklusiv
hierbei bild live was gibt dir durch den
kopf wenn du die bilder sieht von feiern
in russen mitten in europa was sind die
nissan ist
russland ist kritisieren europa und
kritisieren ziemlich grad
und gleichzeitig hier die nutzung und
genießen europäisch werden systema der
europäische medizin die europäische
service und das klingt nicht so gut
wären von einer seite
ukraine sterben und bereiche rufen
weiter
leben genießen in europa jetzt gab es
seit wochen monaten so heißt es keine
waffenlieferungen oder große
waffenlieferungen insbesondere aus
deutschland und auch aus europa wie
enttäuscht bist du ich bin sehr
enttäuscht weil er ohne waffen wenig
trost stoppen und rufen marschiert
weiter und machen die wirkung
bekommen war von aber nie genug genug
wird werden
verletzt
was konkret bräuchte man von deutschland
insbesondere diesen tag ich bin keine
militärexperte jetzt im moment ich weiß
dass es sehr großen ort in
schwere waffen weil das meine ich gleich
die ganze die trommel flugzeuge
weil er bekämpfen und verteidigen habe
schon gesagt wie viel zeit ich im licht
unserer familie wie gesagt 'junge europa
wir verteidigen jede in europa weil die
russen gehen so weit wie weit wir
glauben ihm zu gehen und deswegen
deswegen man muss nicht vergessen
das ist eine blutige krieg läuft und
hochrhein und wir zahlen für frieden in
europa mit großer zahl mit leben unserer
bürger sechs monaten krieg in der
ukraine was hat das mit dir persönlich
gemacht und wie sehr hat sich hast du
dich dadurch verändert würde glaube ich
dass es eine große wie ich bin fest
überzeugt dass es eine große tragödie
für ganz kleine das ist die leben von
millionen von menschen verändert und
meinen leben persönlich hier hat auch
sehr verändert habe ich meine familie
mehr als sechs monate nie gesehen ich
kann nicht mal eine stadt verlassen ich
mache
nur dienst jetzt im moment service an
menschen zu geben menschen zu schützen
das ist sehr wichtig und hier zum meer
und zudem ja sicher kreis bild der
nummer 1 in unserem land glaube ich
immer in die ganze welt und deswegen
deswegen
das ist eine arbeit non stop und die
seen unglückliche menschen hat seine
zuhause verloren man kann seine freunde
vorbei und verwandten verloren dass es
ist ist recht wie
das interview führte paul ronzheimer uns
jetzt auch zugeschaltet paul mann hatte
es immer noch große enttäuschung auch
gegenüber deutschland fährst du das
aufgefasst
ihr mann hat sie überhaupt in der
ukraine dass sich das wirklich endgültig
verändert hat also angefangen mit der
zeitenwende dann die diskussion die
kritik die wut zwischen selensky scholz
steinmeier wir erinnern uns alles im
april mai juni und dann gab es ja so ein
bisschen erlösung hat man gehört hat
gebhardt kanzler werden geliefert wir
haben von weiteren waffenlieferungen
gehört aber jetzt stockt wieder alles
und das ist das gefährliche denn im
osten da ist die front etwas eingefroren
die russen kommen langsam voran aber die
ukraine die wollen vor allem im süden
etwas befreien person irgendwann mario
puzo der traum aber mit dem was sie
jetzt scheint das völlig unrealistisch
und das bedeutet es ist ein endloser
abnutzungskrieg so nennt man das in der
militärischen sprache nämlich dann wenn
die eine und die andere front nicht
vorankommt jetzt ziehen wir dich paul
mitten in kiew und du stehst nicht vom
ukrainischen panzern und nicht von
westlichen panzern die der etwa dahin
geliefert worden wären sondern von
russischen panzern das ist quasi eine
russische panzer parade mitten in kiew
so was wie eine beute parade
so kann man das nennen ja ich bin
gestern hierher gekommen da waren am
sonntag tausende menschen auf der straße
sind auch diese panzer hier hinter mir
drauf gesprungen haben regelrecht
gefeiert und sie haben sozusagen hier
mein buch wenn man hier weitergeht das
ist eine ganze reihe von panzern die
hier steht und die ukraine witzeln
darüber und sagen schau tanja das ist
die siegesparaden die lade mir putin
soll im februar märz wollte als er
dachte in wenigen tagen steht er hier in
der hauptstadt auf dem majdan mit seinen
soldaten und hat die ukraine erobert und
das noch symbolisch zeigen schaut her
schauer wladimir putin das sind deine
panzer und auch deine opfer denn das
muss man ja traurigerweise sagen da
saßen russische soldaten die gestorben
sind in diesen panzer nämlich als sie
hier einfach in den krieg geschickt
wurden und dachten sie könnten die
ukraine überreden dass ein symbolisches
zeichen in einer woche die sehr
symbolisch ist denn der unabhängigkeit
der ukraine abhängigkeits tag der
ukraine steht am 24
da hat man sorge bereits wieder dass
russland erneut versuchen könnte auch
die hauptstadt hier anzugreifen
[Musik]